comment vont les victimes husky
notamment conducteur encore à l'hôpital
à Beaujon
il masque
le cousin du conducteur comment comment
il est on ne vient de l'hôpital on est
parti voir le XL ouais
par rapport à avant maintenant et on
sent un peu bien d'accord et pour
l'instant il part je réponds 15
médicaments pour calmer le dans l'ordre
tout ça 15 médicaments et plus depuis
que d'accord je vais parler avec lui il
lui décroche je prends pas médicament je
vais éviter le médicament ça m'a fait
beaucoup de mal on pense fort à lui
beaucoup de monde obligé et faire le
donner beaucoup de médicaments pour
faire le calmer de l'odeur il a eu
beaucoup d'organes touchés
il était opéré cette fois je regardais
comment il était opéré les ventes pour
mais tu le regain de sa place
et
il mange pas beaucoup il est décan
j'aime manger beaucoup ça m'a fait trop
mal psychologiquement il est comment
il parle avec le normal il rappelle pas
d'accident
et pour l'instant il dit je ne sais pas
comment qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors
stylo est-ce qu'il est donc il reparle
là
il marche pas pour l'instant il marche
pas
dans son lit il fait le
massage pour le
sait que c'est Pierre Palmade qui était
dans la voiture et qu'il a fait
l'accident il le sait ça il attendait il
connaît pas pierre Palma on a décidé un
artiste
avec lui d'accord
on sait quand il pourra sortir de
l'hôpital le conducteur pas du tout pour
l'instant
pour l'instant il a rien dit et il va
rester quelques mois encore là-bas
d'accord et ça dépend de
pour l'instant et quand il promet des
camos ils sont rien quand il a arrêté
médicament ça dépend de
médicaments qu'il a arrêté après il va
voir il est bien provient aujourd'hui
d'accord il a tout le côté gauche très
abîmé c'est exactement même à droite
aussi le pied à droite
de gauche le pied
les épaules les bras
je il m'a dit je me sens pas mes bras
gauche
il y a une
vent il a il a été croisé et le sang il
marche pas très bien et c'est pour ça
c'est je me sens pas bien ok alors
est-ce qu'il y aura des séquelles la vie
qu'est-ce que disent les médecins les
médecins disent qu'il aura des séquelles
la vie et c'est quel pour la semaine n'a
rien dit d'accord pour l'instant on n'en
sait pas plus
de 6 ans lui il est sorti de l'hôpital
fils de XL il est sorti de Necker lui
quand il va et lui dire
il va à l'école il marche avec un Corse
d'accord et il est retourné à l'école il
a tourné le code de plus d'accord Homer
tu me disais tu me disais la dernière
fois qu'il n'arrivait pas trop à marcher
il n'y a parlé ça s'est amélioré à
marcher un peu plus mais parler encore
moins ah oui parce qu'il a vraiment trop
mal et encore 24 ou 25 séances à aller
voir son médecin d'accord il est
toujours sous médicament un peu
pas faire des crises d'épilepsie
et il continue comme il est conscient de
ce qui lui est arrivé même à son âge il
se rappelait pas du tout il sait pas
exactement ce qui m'est arrivé non non
on lui a demandé mais comme son père il
savait quoi d'accord
donc là il retourné à l'école à l'école
comment il va psychologiquement il est
comment il va le matin mais il se
fatigue beaucoup trop l'après-midi donc
après midi il peut plus aller il se
repose et vu qu'il doit prendre toujours
des médicaments ça lui fatigue trop et
il a envie de dormir alors on va parler
maintenant de Mirail après vous allez
nous dire on va parler de la décision de
justice Mira la femme qui a perdu son
bébé donc qui est
donc la femme de votre
non c'est pas ça c'est quoi c'est c'est
la femme du beau-frère
c'est comment elle va elle surtout bah
elle c'est surtout déjà physiquement
comment elle est
j'ai parlé avec parce que ma rue de Mira
c'est ami de mon frère monsieur j'ai
fait rappeler la parler avec lui
il est des fois quand il réveillait
pleurer il est toujours pleurer ça fait
longtemps il devrait être en devoir un
bébé et quand il perdue son bébé il a
des yeux plus voir un enfant après et
toujours dans notre section qui est pas
bien
personnel est-ce qu'elle va mieux toute
façon elle est mieux il est mieux et
toujours pensé son bébé bien sûr c'est
psychologiquement quel est le plus
exactement il est pas bien et penser son
bébé et en plus je crois qu'elle avait
eu du mal à avoir un enfant exactement
[Musique]
son mari comment il a réagi ça m'arrive
laissé de la semaine
parce que une mère c'est son père et
perdre une il attendait son bébé et il
attendait il est mort
c'est triste pour tout le monde pour un
papa pour une alors on va on va revenir
sur la décision de justice puisque
aujourd'hui Pierre Palma est libre libre
presque totalement alors il est libre à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital voilà mais il
n'a pas de bracelet il est sous contrôle
judiciaire il n'est plus écroué il n'est
plus gardé si son état de santé le
permet il peut se déplacer à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital voilà et ça ça va durer
jusqu'à ce que éventuellement le juge
dise maintenant il serait en état d'être
écroué de nouveau mais pour le moment ça
paraît improbable et l'instruction
continue comme ça voilà j'avais bien sûr
suivi la décision de justice le mardi
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez every
[Musique]
en prison c'est mon oncle parce qu'il
est coulait sur son lit d'Opale
Pierre Balmain il est en pleine forme là
il est juste à l'hôpital il peut faire
ce qu'il veut à l'intérieur
mais la décision du 6 un peu mais nous
notre priorité c'est pas qu'il aille en
prison nous on veut bien qu'il aille en
prison mais a priorité c'est la santé de
mon oncle d'abord monsieur pour vous sa
place elle est où elle est voilà c'est
c'est vous lui en voulez ou pas du tout
dès le début quand j'ai attendu la
justice on attendait il a dit bracelet
mais moi j'ai des tuiles tout le temps
ça veut dire c'est une bon cadeau c'est
une bonne image pour les gens qui comme
les prendre la drogue tout ça je suis
désolé et quand j'ai attendu qu'il
devrait faire soigner à l'hôpital
pour lui c'est une antenne 5 étoiles
je préfère tout ce que vous pensez on
préfère mission pierre Palma il va être
en prison dans une chambre privée
soigner là-bas c'est mieux pour lui une
exemple pour le justice France
excuse-moi c'est une exemple pour les
autres qui prendront que ça va faciliter
et donner faciliter pour les gens et
puis vivre comme il veut ça veut dire
moi je prends la route je prends drogue
je fais accident je suis deux familles
de vue de famille je tuer quelqu'un
c'est pas grave il a pris
il est en prison même les juger
excuse-moi même il est jugé il devrait
rester dans une chambre de prison
hôpital pour nous c'est pas en prison
d'accord je suis désolé donc vous êtes
déçu de la décision du 6 moi je suis
personnellement je suis déçu vous
vous en voulez à la justice aujourd'hui
comment vous en voulez à la justice vous
avez envie qu'elle est voilà que vous
avez envie qu'il
tout ce qu'il en a dit quand je veux
bien les justices il fait son travail
correct
il fait soin là pour l'instant pour nous
le justice et les côtés de Monsieur
apparemment nous on est heureux devant
le justice parce qu'on est pas plus fort
comme lui la vérité il faut parler
2021 24 avril 2021 je fais un accident
comme mon cousin uxel
l'opération qui est l'entrée dans ma
voiture il est feu rouge il était 15 ans
et notre avocat
il a fait il a fait on a fait pour te
prendre le monsieur il était en prison
depuis 2 ans il est en prison il vit une
Africaine excuse-moi je suis pas raciste
une africain pauvre il a pris deux ans
de prison vite fait il faut qu'on se
fait apparaître c'est une artiste c'est
pour ça c'est ça c'est ce que disait Yin
masse il veut évoquer ce point parce que
pour lui il y a une justice pour les
riches une justice pour les peaux
vous pour vous si c'était pas Pierre
Palmade il aurait été incarcéré
directement pour moi c'est notre place
c'est une Française excuse-moi mais
c'est un autre quelqu'un à vous pensez
ça excuse-moi je suis désolé pour nous
juxel pour notre famille ce soir nous
une français juste survêt juste
il va jusqu'à bout il va mettre en prise
de positionner dans Présent pas dans un
hôpital c'est dur
parce que pour quand je dis ça moi je
fais le même accident comme mon cousin
c'est ça et lui il est en présence parce
qu'il est pauvre vous avez fait vous
avez été victime vous-même d'un accident
similaire il y a quelques années un
mineur brûle un feu rouge et percute
votre voiture un peu et lui il a été
avec mes filles donc on va trouver l'été
partez nos rapports une accident de
Mortal nous on n'est pas Alté blessé
comme le XL et le monsieur qui est mis
sur Kenzo il a fait il a il est en
prison depuis 2 ans
et pourquoi lui Sofia un grand accident
après le procès il va arriver
je pensais dotation on n'a pas blessé
d'accident il y a deux ans présent et
plus cette personne me soigne pas mais
détruit de famille une paire est décédée
je suis une paire de famille il est déjà
dans le lit il arrive pas est-ce qu'il
va marcher ou pas on sait pas depuis le
traumatisme exactement alors
vous voulez revenir aussi sur une autre
info les infos de Paris Match la semaine
dernière consacré ça une à l'affaire
Pierre Palmade est plus précisément à
Muriel Robin lorsqu'on lisait l'article
on en a on a la prenait un peu plus sur
la visite de Muriel Robin à l'hôpital du
Kremlin-Bicêtre le 10 février dernier au
soir quelques heures après le terrible
accident au soir de l'accident Muriel
Robin s'est précipité au chevet de
Pierre Palmade à l'hôpital du
Kremlin-Bicêtre il venait d'être
transféré Anne sa compagne était à ses
côtés elle ne savait pas encore ce qui
s'était réellement passé avant
l'accident ni ce qu'il avait provoqué au
détour des couloirs la comédienne a
croisé la famille que son ami a brisé à
la fondue aux larmes dans leurs bras
partageant leur peine se sentant presque
coupable de ne en avoir pu leur éviter
ce drame muriel a décidé de ne plus
aller voir Pierre ce que c'est vrai ça
notre formule du Yakout parce qu'on
n'est pas le même hôpital de lui madame
il a été dans le même hôpital de Pierre
Palma nous on n'a pas vu peut-être il a
vu cette famille n'est pas vue
là-bas
j'ai prévenu ma femme j'ai dit moi
jamais aller hôpital de Pierre Palma il
va comprendre
solidarisiens de de l'enquête d'ailleurs
qui avait été faite dans Paris Match
aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai que Homer et
Yilmaz vous aujourd'hui vous auriez vous
le dites préférés que Pierre Palmade
soit directement incarcéré c'est bien ça
c'est pas notre priorité mais on a bien
qu'il a en prison qu'est-ce qu'ils
disent qu'est-ce qu'ils disent les
victimes leur avait dit ça que la
personne qui qui avait qui les avait
percuté pour l'instant était remise en
liberté avant le procès leur avait dit à
votre famille oui on leur a dit ils ont
pas vraiment compris pourquoi c'était
cette décision d'accord parce que aussi
vous qui l'avez en prison purger sa
peine
vous trouvez méchant non un truc chaud
ah d'accord à l'aide de mission
il va sonner dans une heure plus tard
avant on a dit branler c'est un bon
cadeau maintenant c'est les paradis pour
lui hôpital il va rester hôpital
on va voir le mardi qu'est-ce qui va
donner
on va voir ce que ça va donner oui
Mathieu oui pardon c'est vrai que
Jean-Marie Bigard sur ce plateau a dit
un jour qu'il avait pardonné à la salsa
de son père qui avait mis 12 coups de
couteau c'est dur à croire mais ma
question c'est est-ce que vous pensez
qu'un jour avec beaucoup de prison ou
pas vous pourrez vous pourrez lui
pardonner
j'espère mais surtout il va soigner on
veut plus voir deuxième accident comme
ça arrivait on veut éviter
accédant comme Monsieur Pierre Palma il
faut arrêter les gens comme ça dans les
propriétés de conduite véhicule il faut
arrêter moi je veux bien justice j'ai
fait son travail après j'espère mon
cousin il va être marcher il va être
bien on sait pas y avoir de rester
handicapés ou pas c'est quoi ça a été
quoi votre action dites la vérité aux
mairie et le masque quand vous avez
appris chose et quand vous avez appris
qu'il avait été voilà sous emprise de
stupéfiant vous êtes dit quoi vous êtes
dit c'est inadmissible vous êtes dit que
le responsable c'est quoi vous êtes dit
quoi on a dit que c'était responsable
c'était un truc qu'il fallait pas qu'il
fasse il a des restos mais c'est pas ça
faut parler peut-être à cause de drogue
s'il apprend pas de robe combien fois
l'arrêter par la police il a été laissé
il a pas récupéré son permis si il a
plus permis peut-être pas dur
donc vous en voulez aussi la justice
bien sûr oui oui et je veux savoir si
Pierre Palmade était de rentrer en
contact avec votre famille pour
peut-être vous demander pardon ou
s'expliquer ou essayer de vous voir les
questions on peut pardonner tout le
temps on peut accepter les partenaires
tout le temps on n'est pas là contre
Pierre pas mais on est là contre les
accidents de vous voir de vous appeler
il peut venir par là pour pour voir on
n'est pas là contredit pour voir les
faire de mal on est là pour la justice
et son travail
si les justices de données
hôpital il peut sortir ce soir il peut
aller profiter comme il veut on n'est
pas avec lui excuse-moi vous avez pas de
haine contre lui ce que je trouve assez
beau comme ça
accident peut-être il peut tomber sur
vous vous êtes sur une algérien une
Marocaine n'importe quel
tunisien par exemple
mais bon
il est en cours jusqu'à 20 ans de prison
puisqu'il est en récidive est-ce que
pour vous ce serait une peine qui serait
logique pour vous est-ce que s'il
prenait vraiment 20 ans de prison parce
que c'est dans les textes de loi en tout
cas c'est dans les textes plus lois on
sait pas ce qui se passera mais est-ce
que c'est ce que vous souhaitez que
vraiment qui est vraiment un jugement
qui soit extrêmement sévère à son égard
moi je dis le début
je lui souhaite il va payer tout ce
qu'il a fait mal il va payer tout ça
il a droit à rester en prison il va
rester 20 ans en prison il faut rester
pro et peut-être rester en prison c'est
mieux pour lui il va se soigner va
sortir comme un homme comme on veut bien
regarder toujours son visage lui il
pourrait faire être propre devant les
peuples devant les gens on prend son
caractère
essayez de mauvaise image pour les gens
vraiment ça ne ça pas bon pour tout le
monde mais vraiment moi j'ai condamné ce
qui avait fait Pierre Palmade ici et
durement et on me l'a on me l'a reproché
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
et je vous soutiens entièrement jusque
pour le mettre en prison aujourd'hui
comme vous dites c'est que la claque je
suis pas très d'accord parce que ici les
malades et qu'il a fait un AVC et qu'il
est pas en capacité d'être mis devant un
tribunal il vaut mieux qu'il aille
d'abord à l'hôpital qui se soigne
correctement et une fois qu'il est
capable d'être devant un tribunal qu'il
aille devant un tribunal et qui paye la
récidive comme l'a dit Amélie et qui
pèse qui doit payer parce que dans cet
accident malheureusement il y a eu
quelqu'un de tuer et comme vous dites
des fois juste au feu rouge le gars a
pris deux ans on voit des gens juste
pour des bagarres qui prennent du ferme
juste pour des bagarres sans tuer
personne donc voilà juste je dis je suis
avec vous mais c'est d'abord on le
soigne et apprendre des questions un
jour il y aura un procès c'est à peu
près sûr est-ce que vous avez envie
d'être confronté à Pierre Palmade
qu'est-ce que vous lui diriez si vous
êtes face à lui le jour du procès
qu'est-ce que je veux dire je veux dire
il faut
il faut arrêter il faut arrêter de
continuer comme ta vie avant vous restez
pro la vérité
drogué drogué droguer changer sa vie il
faut changer ta vie je veux dire
c'est mieux pour lui
je trouve que vous avez beaucoup
d'indulgence pour lui je pense que vous
auriez plus vous connaissiez ou pas
avant
je regardais son
il était endamari quand on arrive
oui on a discipline qui va faire
et donc ouais moi en plus quand il a à
cause de Pierre palmain il y en a chez
nous un tremblerre moi j'ai ouvert mon
salle de mariage pour voir le don on va
les Turquie
le jeudi j'ai commencé vendredi
là j'ai arrêté tout les temps pour le
Turquie là-bas on est mal au cœur ils
sont on est mal au cœur pour 15 raisons
on a pourquoi à cause de Pierre pas mal
à cause de son drogue tout ça ça
vraiment il faut arrêter